[Music]
are you seated i am
no actually i'm just this short
i want to do an explainer on the mobius
strip oh sweet so from the matrix
that's more that's morphe okay never
mind not the morpheus strip not the
morpheus strip
mobius
mathematical curiosity that's simple
it's simple so so i have a little arts
and craftsy thing here so what i got
so i have just a strip of paper right
see this that's all it is okay and just
so we understand what's going on here
i'm just going to
tape it into a rib into a closed loop
okay closed loop
that's all i'm going to do
okay okay
got that got it okay nothing
nothing on weird it's just a loop of
paper just a loop of paper and
it has two sides there's an inside and
an outside see that
heading outside all right
no problem
if i were to cut this in half
let's go ahead and do that
so i've got scissors
i'm just going to sit here and cut it in
half
okay okay what should i get after i cut
this in half
two loops of paper yeah
let's see
just kind of just not magic or anything
okay
[Laughter]
that's so funny
obvious magic by neil degrasse tyson
right watch me put them watch me pull a
rabbit out of my hat come here rabbits
okay so we got that okay so now
let me get the next one
right so instead of attaching it that
way
i'm
going
to
[Music]
give it a
full twist
okay
okay so not
halfway but again
okay
so there we go that's a full twist
and so i'm gonna put a little piece of
tape
on each side
and now we can ask
okay
that looks like a like a figure eight
looks like a figure eight that's kind of
cool
right right okay
and
let me see
uh this also has
two different sides so if i were to sort
of draw a line on it let's see what we
have here
let's just start here
and i come back to where i started
okay okay so i came back to where i
started so that's one side of the paper
one side and the other side had i didn't
hit the other side right
okay so this also has two sides
like the first one
okay
and if i cut it
in half
let's see what happens here
and
i'm cutting it in half same same way
going down the center same way going
down the center line
and this one i've drawn
and almost done
and
there
so
now i have two
except they are
tangled they're entangled yeah that's
kind of interesting yeah that's nice
that something different happened there
right i just make two different things
so
i have two hoops that are now entangled
so it's not magic it's just
mathematical topology all right there
you go paper handcuffs okay
neither of those are mobius strips okay
gotcha i'm gonna take my third and final
strip
my third and final strip
and i'm gonna give it a half turn just a
half turn a half turn
that's in between the other two okay
okay here we go
and don't try this at home
[Laughter]
all right
that's the day in the news neil degrasse
tyson dies in a tragic mobius strip
experiment
as the paper exploded
halfway around the half term
warning so this mobius strip
has only one side
all right so you say of course it has
two sizes this side and then on the
other side and the outside no
it has only one side so you say how
could a thing have only one side of
course there are two sides what's going
on well one way to show it is let's draw
a line again and if i never cross over
the edge
that counts as staying on the same side
wouldn't it chuck of course yes all
right of course it does okay
so let's go ahead
and once again i'm gonna see if i can do
this anymore
[Applause]
okay i'm back to where i started back to
where you started okay right there all
right okay the anticipation is killing
me i don't know what is going to happen
okay back to where i started
and notice
both sides
have lines on them oh
snap
okay
both sides
which means
it only had one side
right
oh my gosh there's only one side to this
i never went around the edge and i went
and i
covered all
surfaces of this
without ever crossing the edge of this
piece of paper so it is a one-sided
structure
okay yes so now
so you're oh wow now you're on the
inside and the outside at the same time
but you only stayed on one side
correct oh my god
that's so cool so it's a one-sided
object now what's harder for me to
demonstrate but i'll just have to tell
you
is that if we lived in this world
and you had um
a mitten
okay
if you had a mitten
well a mitten is going to be a
right-handed mitten or a left hand a
glove a right-handed or a left-handed
okay
all right and let's say you let's say
you had two gloves and you lost one
so now you have only or
you have two sets of gloves and you've
lost
the left pair of each of those two
gloves you have two right-handed gloves
that sounds about my life yeah okay you
can take
one of those right-handed gloves
move it through this
and on the other side it becomes a
left-handed glove oh wow
so you can change
the orientation of the glove by the time
it returns to where it was before it'll
be on the other side of the sheet of
paper but you would have turned it from
a left-handed glove to the right-handed
glove and it's still part of the
universe that is the sheet of paper
right
so this is it this can change your
handedness
it has one side
and
if i cut it in half okay this is one of
the only objects for which this is true
if i take it
and i'm just going to cut it right down
the middle
just like i did the other two
so let's do this
and here i go
and i'm cutting
and they're cutting
bam
i just cut it in two
and it's a single oh
my goodness
okay
wow
bam mobius strip
on your face that is an amazing oh man i
know what i'm doing at my next cocktail
party
so moby strips are fascinating now i
gave you instructions before this call
to to to make your own mobius strip out
of paper you got you have that one and i
did i did you did very nice i made this
trick so it's beautiful to look at or
you can like mess with it and by the way
it's easier to draw the line if you
slide it under when you have a tabletop
you just slide it under right and then
that'll work much more effectively than
me doing it in midair here
right so chuck i hear you're going to be
giving away mobius strips for for for
holiday gifts so anyway so you told me
to make my own mobius strip and you know
my new favorite thing in the world is
the glowforge which is a 3d laser
printer that will
cut things out of i don't know what i
mean if you want to engrave if you want
to cut but i made a mobius strip that's
very geeky of you to do
well guess what
and listen to this listen to this so all
these little cuts here that my friend so
it made it flexible out of wood it it
turned the wood into this continuous
hinge you said that's that is a piece of
wood that you bent into a momentum this
is a piece of wood that i painted once i
was done because you know i'm i'm crafty
like that right and then so check this
out though so the same way that that we
just did it with the paper right look at
this
okay
okay so you painted it
so i painted it two different colors so
you can see both sides okay
what's that black
of course
the depths of space are returned to the
blackness all right so so what you did
so you gave it a half twist i gave it a
half twist okay but here's your problem
chuck what you painted it before you
turned it into a mobius strip
correct because you think what you just
created has two sides
but it doesn't and it doesn't right
because the red side blends straight
into the black side and vice versa well
you can see it if you look at it it's
like look
this is the black side and the red side
at the same time
coming together
we are the world it's amazing
not only have i created a mobius strip
i have actually solved race relations in
the world
two colors come together as one as one
brought to you by glowfords
[Laughter]
glowfords solving the problems of race
relations in the world it's the same
side look at that isn't that amazing
that's beautiful that that's beautiful
okay so together and it's the same size
you wouldn't want to cut that the way i
cut this but that that's a good
showpiece on the counter yeah and but if
i mean if i were to cut it it would do
the same thing you did it would just
become one long time it would become one
long twisted price but i'm not doing
that i'm by the oh my god wait a minute
i wonder
if i could
cut that inside of my glowford okay now
i got a new project okay now you worry
me now you can this is how superhero
nemesis is get
formed i have an idea
however i have to tell you this is my
new favorite thing in the world i
i'm glow forging everything now
because you can
and i you know i've always been kind of
crafty but never
like always little projects but i'm
telling you right now i am making
everything from glass etched pictures
for people to
wallets for the people that i don't like
i just take a while and engrave it just
like here you go and
to mobius strips
everyone will know if they got a wallet
from you you don't like their ass but
guess what i'm glad they will so because
you should be nicer to me and you would
get nicer glowforge products
if you were nicer to me you would get
nicer glowforge products from me
okay but instead you're gonna get a
wallet
okay
look with your name on it you're lucky
you don't get a wallet that i engraved
with the letters cheap so
but yeah uh anyway i'm just i'm in love
with this thing i can't wait to see what
else i'm glow forging everything okay so
now just so you know just to take this
one take this up a notch yes
if a
mobius strip is a two-dimensional sheet
of paper right right that you twisted
this way
you can wonder if you're a mathematician
what would a mobius strip be like
in higher dimensions
you can up it a notch and now you can
have a mobius strip in three dimensions
and that has a name
it's called a klein bottle yes oh my god
what what
okay so before we did this the only
thing i knew about a mobius strip
because i didn't i'm going to be very
honest i
i'm embarrassed but i really didn't know
about movie you didn't know all the all
the cool stuff about it i didn't know i
didn't know any of this stuff until you
told me to make one and then i made it
on the glow forge and all that right
the only thing i did know
was from this short story that i read
way back long time ago about a climb
bottle and that's the only thing that i
know about moebius you read a story
about it okay very cool very that's a
geeky kid right there so
i think i even know what short story
that was oh really yeah i have a book of
math
short stories
that i read as when i was in middle
school and one of them was now that's a
geeky a klein bottle
and another one was a subway system
where where the subway actually traveled
around the path of a mobius strip
absolutely and and so the stations look
different each time you went around but
it was still the same route but but so
it's a fun geeky thing i did i remember
when i was in middle school but so a
klein bottle yes
while a mobius strip has only one side
there's no top and a bottom a klein
bottle
has no inside inside because the inside
is the outside the inside
is part of the outside so and it's its
features are are mathematically similar
but just
jacked up a dimension in order for that
to happen so now you just gave me an
idea for my next mathematical thing that
i'm going to create
well i don't know if it's possible but i
bet you it is which is a tesseract so
because you
drew
this cube of a cube
so that it's the
four-dimensional cube yeah yeah i got
one of those i have one in in my office
i i'm simply calling it a
four-dimensional cube rather than the
secret of all the power in the marvel
universe i will not admit to that
but i do have one uh next time i'm in my
office i'll make sure we maybe we can do
an explainer from there and i'll pull it
out yeah yeah all right well i'm going
to try and print one just in case okay
if it starts flowing call me
[Laughter]
all right we got to call it quits there
john good to have you definitely it's
been start talk explainer low b strips
i'm neil degrasse tyson keep looking up
[Music]
you